let's do a fast round here is uh al
franken um on cnn yeah another what was
that that's coming up actually
this is this is crazy this has been
going around we actually tried to pull
this video i don't know if something's
wrong with cnn's feed or something it
was hard to find a decent video um i i
think the deep state was trying to shut
up al franken here because he was saying
he was saying the truth way out loud
yes when he's saying what is going to
happen um because i think i think this
is why people are so engaged is because
it is clear now more than ever that they
are not only willing to let people lose
their rights it is their goal listen
the legitimacy of the court was
undermined when they wouldn't take up
merrick garland
and you'll remember that mcconnell said
it was because it was during an election
year and you remember lindsey graham
pledging
that if a vacancy came
uh
came open during an election year in uh
20 that he wouldn't
vote for um they wouldn't they wouldn't
take up a nominee they've stolen two
seats
the one that merrick garland
wasn't given a hearing for
and the one that coney barrett was
where she was seated
a week before the election
that
destroyed the legitimacy of the court
alice what do you think did chief
justice roberts sort of
i mean he sort of uh ignored
some of what al is talking about there
and that there is i mean
a tremendous amount of controversy
as to how this court got tilted in the
direction of the far right just to
throw a little accuracy and some of what
al said there look the the merrick
garland
was held up because we had a divided
government we had a democrat in the
white house and we had republicans in
control of that's not what was said
that's not what mcconnell said
but
but that's the way
historically this has been when you're
in close to an election year and you
have divided government yes yes
historically yes when you have divided
government there typically is a
inclination to tell me when this
happened before
when you
when you were close to another
when you're well merrick garland
divided government no before
they're moving they're not moving
forward tell me when this happened
before
al i'm telling you this is what
tell me when it happened before i can't
this is what happened historically tell
me when it happened before look this is
the way that the republicans
went
i can't give you an exact example of
when this happened
because it hadn't happened before
oh my god al franken
look
i'm not saying al franken should or
shouldn't be a senator but he definitely
should be a senator again yeah something
somewhere he should be sitting in a
chair questioning these [ __ ] he
used to do this in the senate in these
committee hearings yeah he used to do it
so well like he would dissect these
people now here he's a little more um
less
you know what do you want to call it uh
diplomatic i guess about his questioning
well i think you know just like [ __ ]
come
i mean like you know obviously we've
seen far worse from representatives on
the republican side you know or senators
but
in this moment you know he's a private
citizen he's just they are speaking his
mind and in this
when did they say it when did they say
it legitimately
oh well i
look i it's it almost sounded like we
were having a bad connection on the
phone with someone right like that's how
much she was doing and breaking up her
speech
this well it because she was challenged
and here's the thing at the end of the
day this is what we need to do too many
times we've seen some person on the
right come on and spew some [ __ ]
misinformation lies and they just accept
it and they go okay next question and
they do not challenge it